if you can wake up every morning knowing
that you're doing what you're called to
do it gives you this great enjoyment of
purpose such as a sense of purpose but a
real enjoyment of purpose so work has
never worked for me I fall in love with
my clients and I don't fall in love with
you I probably won't take you as a
client welcome to 20 minute leaders just
sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I am with Patrick thien the CEO of
Rhythm Systems Inc Patrick is an
international speaker CEO coach and
serial entrepreneur he is a USA Today
and Wall Street Journal best-selling
author his work has been seen on NBC CBS
and fox Patrick was named Ernest and
Young entrepreneur of the year in 1996
for North Carolina as he grew his first
company to number 151 on the Inc 500 now
called the Inc 5000 after a successful
exit he has been on a mission to help
CEOs build great companies and achieve
their dreams
appreciate you being here all the way
from North Carolina and Patrick as a
seasoned entrepreneur managed to grow a
fabulous company which was ranked 151st
on the Inc 500 in 1996. it's still I was
born and so quite quite a few bit of
mileage until then but since then
positioning yourself as a coach
um as a mentor and as an ally to CEOs
building great companies and so um as
the CEO of Rhythm systems I'm excited to
pick your brain on your own Journey on
what made you transition to to now
working with a variety of CEOs rather
than be a company Builder and and some
of the things that you've learned
working with CEOs on things that we can
all take into account I just mentioned
to you and my own New Journey so I'm
excited to write down notes for myself
as well over these 20 minutes and so
Patrick again thank you for being here
yeah so a little bit about myself I'm
actually an engineer solve a technical
background I went to work for Oracle
Corporation Street out of school and
um when I finished at Cornell I went to
Oracle and I joined the Consulting unit
so back in those days 1988 Consulting
was building software for clients you
know so custom software for big
Enterprise systems and um in 91 I
started my firm medicines and we focused
on transportations and Logistics
software good has successfully Inc 500
as I mentioned before as you mentioned
before and I sold it after seven years
now along the way I would say that we
had a number of near-death experiences
you know like the company almost failed
number of times the outside looking in
the company looked very successful from
the inside looking out
there was a lot of fear and concern so
that was my own personal Journey where I
feel like I was fortunate enough to have
problems but solve them before I got
squashed and I succeeded uh I'm a Serial
entrepreneur this is my fourth company
that I'm doing and what I learned in my
first one gave me a passion to help
people help CEOs entrepreneurs succeed
and and what I what I experienced is
that the rate of success of CEO
entrepreneur is actually very low it's
pretty hard to succeed in in the space
that we're in and so I develop a passion
probably because of my own like I said
almost failures number of times to to
really help people succeed that's what I
do today today you know Rhythm systems
we we have a methodology to help you
succeed we have software to record your
goals and your priorities and how you
can make a commitment and then we have a
coaching Consulting practice that helps
you put it all together so that's kind
of what we do today
so being a CEO is um it's kind of time
consuming right you have a lot of fires
to put out you have constantly things to
do and very little sleep how do you
reason through coaching these systemic
things that you're offering how does
this play into the lifestyle of a CEO
where the traditional response always is
I don't have time yeah so the it's a
paradox it's a paradox in the irony is
that oftentimes you don't have time but
you've got to make time for some things
where I would suggest you know you go
slower a little bit so it can go faster
and so what what we really help people
to is we want to put in a rhythm for you
and and just like breathing you know
just like you don't have to think about
breathing your your body activates your
breathing automatically you don't have
to think oh time to take a breath right
so likewise if we put a framework into
your company that gives you a real them
a rhythm to think about your problems a
rhythm to plan a rhythm to actually do
the work then you have a framework and a
system to process the the chaos that
surrounds you as an entrepreneur one of
our clients uh CEO of avid exchange they
went public back in October Michael
Prager he we we actually coached him I
coached him for about three to two years
from the very start wow to where he is
today and what he would say uh he wrote
the forward for my book Rhythm which is
a Wall Street Journal best selling book
right now and he wrote the photo he said
in the book that uh that Rhythm gives
him a a system of framework to process
the chaos that's around him so so today
Avid exchange has uh you know almost 2
000 employees there are public company
on the NASDAQ Stock Exchange and there's
still chaos you will always have chaos
the question is can you manage a chaos
so that you don't get a credit Isis can
you manage the chaos can you thrive on
the Chaos versus your chaos becoming a
crisis
wow if you're very becoming crisis I
love that and so
take me back to when you just started
working with the First with the first
CEOs as you made that first transition
from company Builder to CEO Ally what
was that like for you those really early
days you know in the early days I didn't
do this because I wanted to start a
business I did it only because I was
trying to help people so when I sold
medicines back in 1998 I um I want to
give back to my community so here in
Charlotte I co-found I co-started uh
entrepreneurs Organization for Charlotte
and it was a branch of Yale in the old
days it used to be called White Leo
young entrepreneurs organization now
it's called EO because I guess we all
got all so we just dropped the Y because
entrepreneurs organization and that was
my way of giving back so I started EO
here in Charlotte and a lot of people
asked me for helps they asked me to help
them and at first I did it just to help
them and then I began to realize the
following number one the mistakes I had
made when not uncommon in fact I thought
I was stupid but you know what a lot of
people made the same mistakes as me some
of my friends made even worse mistakes
than me so I really just wanted to help
them at first and um in fact I didn't
even I had I was starting to run another
business I had another startup I created
there's only about five six years later
2005 that I realized my true calling was
to help CEOs not fail but to succeed I
tell you when you figure out
your true calling I just wish that
everybody figures that out younger in
life you know so I was very lucky I mean
I figured it out you know am I am I I
guess around 40 years of age what I was
really passionate about and how I could
help people what does that feel like
though when you're saying figure out the
calling what what does that take me back
take me through the feelings that you
have when you when you discover that
when you figure out your calling it's is
that it's Indescribable it's that
jealousy quality a little something
special that you know you're doing the
right thing and and I always like to say
that you know when when you're doing
what you love to do it's not work and
when people pay you for what you love to
do
that's awesome so that's the spot I
found myself in and I'm a knowledge
Seeker
I don't have a business degree you know
I'm a hack I'm a life hacker and a
business hacker so so I've learned
through my own experiences I've burnt my
hands many times and I've got thousands
of patterns that I've observed of
different companies over the last you
know 20 years I've done workshops and
coaching sessions uh Asia and Europe and
in the US all over the world we have
clients actually in my company we have
clients in all five continents in this
world so we see a lot of patterns a lot
of challenges and um it's great you you
asked a question of how did it how does
it feel I would tell you that if you can
wake up every morning knowing that
you're doing what you're called to do it
gives you this great enjoyment of
purpose such as a sense of purpose but a
real enjoyment of purpose
so work has never worked for me I fall
in love with my clients if I don't fall
in love with you I probably won't take
you as a client I love it that's really
really cool and so what's this process
of falling in love with your clients
like how do you how do you how do you
take this how do you even start such an
engagement where you get to know whether
this is a person that you're going to
spend now 20 something years coaching
yeah I would say I would say the
following I would say you know let me
tell you a story about a mental mind
that unfortunately years ago passed away
from cancer but uh he was my coach and
when when Richard was in his 50s he um
he called me up and he's about 50 years
older than me so he was in his 50s and
he said Patrick you know uh I'm doing my
last gig now and I figured it out he
said I figured out that that I only want
to work with people I love to work with
I don't need any other reason not to
hire you if I don't like you so he said
he said Patrick I really figured out so
I need you to come up to me I was not I
said I said dude I'm running my own
company I'm not going to come work for
you he said no no you don't understand
you are going to come work for me at
some point because I just you all those
people have loved to work you got to go
work for me I said okay okay calm down
Richard so
um unfortunately a few years later he
was diagnosed with brain cancer and he
fought a good fight but a few a couple
years later he passed away so he didn't
live he didn't get the 10 years because
she told me he said Patrick I'm going to
work this my last gig and give it
everything I got 10 years more and I'm
going to finally retire from doing
businesses and I'm going to go to
something else so Richard didn't have
the 10 years that he thought he had to
work in fact he had less than that to
work and to live so it really touched me
deeply and I thought you know what I I'm
gonna decide right now that I'm only
going to work with people that I love
that's it me I don't need a reason other
than I have limited time on God's green
earth and I want every moment to matter
if I coached you I don't care deeply
about you I can't give you my best so
it's not it's not a selfish thing you
know Michael it's it's it's more like if
if I really care deeply about you I will
give you my best and then some right and
and if I care deeply about you I'll be
vulnerable I'll be willing and able to
share some things with you I may not be
able to shift I can't get myself fully
to you so how do I figure if I'm gonna
uh help somebody well number one is do I
even like the person like sometimes you
just can't figure it out some people
like each other and some people don't
it's called chemistry so number one do I
have chemistry number two is the person
that I work with
coachable
I've looked a number of people that
weren't that coachable they thought they
were
but they weren't that coachable so are
you going to be coachable and then and
then is there a connection you know can
we build that basis of trust where we
would enjoy this walk together so uh and
then the last piece I would say is can I
give you value if if I don't feel that I
can give you value or help you solve
your problems I'm gonna I'm gonna take a
pass and so I I can't solve every single
problem but uh I feel like I can give
you value then then you know then we
have something to talk about otherwise
otherwise I'm gonna take a pass and then
what does an engagement look like once
you once you do decide to marry somebody
and say okay we're in this is a match
this is going to be a good journey
together how does this journey look like
so usually our clients I typically help
CEOs of mid-sides companies so these are
companies that are typically 20 million
to a few hundred million in size and
these are companies that have reached
what I call a sense that the hit the
ceiling of complexity okay where
suddenly things got more difficult uh
and life got something got a lot more
complicated so typically what happens is
that we meet each other uh they usually
refer our business is highly referral
based uh they first decide that they
like the methodology that we have and
there are lots of methods out there of
course I believe mine the best but there
are a lot of methods out there so
they've got a first of all decide that
they're going to use by methodology and
then they're going to use my software
for
documenting the goals and the discipline
that their companies need because what I
do is I do coaching for CEOs in a
company right I don't do like coaching
that kind of stuff I do business
coaching and CEO leadership development
for the CEO and to make the company more
successful more effective for the CEO
and so we have the system we have the
software uh and then we typically would
do planning sessions for the company
it's usually a quarterly Rhythm that's
part of a methodology and then the CEO
will spend a couple of hours every month
with me one-on-one I will take out
virtual walks uh and and and discuss any
challenges or any opportunities that
that CEO would like to discuss so I
would say that oftentimes you know in a
coaching part of the engagement I'm much
more like a a mirror a reflector to
allow the CEO to kind of share their
concerns their opportunities get excited
so I have different rules for different
occasions right sometimes I gotta be the
cheerleader to help another cochlear to
go conquer what mountain she or he's
about to to to conquer sometimes they're
going to be the ass kicker sometimes I
just got to be look you're committed to
doing something and you didn't get it
done
dude I'm sorry I gotta kick your ass you
gotta get it done so you know because I
tell you uh companies often fail because
of a lack of ability to execute and to
execute and do the commitments that
they've set commitments to their
customers commitments to their employees
to the shareholders to their suppliers
and pro and partners so a company that
cannot execute as a company is going to
fail in lots of times they blame the
strategy but most of the time I think
you know uh the the the uh the usual
suspect is strategy but usually the
villain is poor execution
right right
it's it sounds incredible and and I have
so many more questions about about your
coaching and it sounds like you're so
committed and you're so devoted to the
success of of your partners and the CEOs
that you're that you're allied with and
it's so it's so it's really inspiring
it's really amazing but but I want to
make sure in in the few short minutes we
have left I want to hear a little bit
about your passion for Samaritan's feet
it's in your it's in your fun fact and
uh it's pretty I got a chance to check
it out a little bit and I and I wanted
to hear from your words a little bit
about what it's about and why this is
something that you're particularly
excited about
Samantha's feet is a non-profit and what
many of whom he's doing with his team is
to put shoes on millions of children so
about 15 years ago or 17 years ago we
got together and Manny and I go way back
Manny I recruited many to medicis out of
school so I've known many a long time
and after I sold medicines I went on to
do other things and a few years later he
called me and said Patrick I'm study
Sparta's feet after this vision from God
to to uh to save children by giving them
shoots and I said why shoot so this is
one historian than mine but he's from
Nigeria uh and a mystery gave him a pair
of shoes and he became a basketball
player came to the U.S on a basketball
scholarship and is successful today he
shared with me that look Patrick I want
to go back to Nigeria I want to go back
to Africa I want to put shoes on kids
because kids there have no shoes and and
no excuse me to come go to school no
shoes means that lots of diseases kind
of go through the the soul the feet and
for some children they die because of
that and so there was this passion so we
talked about Halloween frame all this we
created his first big harry audacious
goal his first long-term goal which is
to put 10 million shoes on 10 million
kids around the world wow and so that
was a long time ago I tell you what it's
about his feet today uh I don't know how
many countries are in already but
they've crossed the 9 million miles
they're like 9.5 wow the choose right
now so we're hoping pray that next year
will get the 10 million mock for for
putting shoes on on people around the
world so that is just unbelievable that
that is a heart that's a heart mission
unbelievable I can only imagine uh
following this closely and being part of
it from the get-go is a must be quite a
journey isn't it I tell you the one
thing that's amazing about spiritus the
process is that we actually first washed
the feet
so imagine this imagine you've you've
been you know you don't have shoes so
your feet are terribly dirty and broken
and everything and and we wash your feet
we dry it and then we put soft soap put
shoes on
and the act of washing your feet that is
a the the the receiver really steals the
love uh from from someone when we go
through the app and it's it's uh it's
beautiful
unbelievable amazing yeah just as
inspiring as your journey into into
coaching
I'd like you to leave me and um
whoever's listening with perhaps
something that you know any of us can
take away whether it be whether we're
CEOs whether we're just leaders in our
own life now I firmly believe
everybody's a leader it's part of also
the Mantra of the show
um we're leading different things uh
whether it be ourselves or others what
is something about leadership About
Management that you've learned and
experienced over the over the last few
decades that they're saying okay this is
something that you know if everybody in
the world grasped perhaps we'd be in a
better place or any every every person
would would augment their own life
through this fundamental understanding
well it's a tough that's a tough
question I would uh there are a few
things that popping into my mind right
now uh I would say I I would like to
share two things if I can the first is
that I suggest that everyone should be
the best version of yourself like figure
out who can help you to be the best
version of yourself a lot of times we
meet someone and we we're so inspired we
want to be like them uh I would suggest
that maybe you don't want to be like you
want being like them is fine but don't
try to be a copy of them right take what
you can learn from them their patterns
and and and create the best version of
yourself and the only other thing I'll
say is that I think that most problems
can be solved uh with the right people
conversation so I have this thing called
spicy conversations spicy conversations
hot conversations the conversations you
don't really want to have because
they're too difficult if you don't have
those conversations uh you create a
seven ton elephant later you know Alice
all seven ton elephants were born in a
small little baby elephants so when
people say how to eat an elephant and
people say one bite at a time I'd say no
let's have the spicy conversation let's
eat the baby elephant right eat the baby
elephant and then it doesn't become a
big town elephant so if you just try to
be the best version of yourself and
focus on making sure you're having those
real conversations with the people
around you I think you'll be a great
leader
incredible incredible Patrick I'm so
thankful for your time and for your
energy
um and uh it left me very inspired from
these 20 minutes so I really appreciate
every minute of it and I look forward to
keeping in touch over over the next
while with my journey as well and so
thank you very much for everything that
that you shared over these 20 minutes
and uh and it was really really great
thank you thanks thanks for having me
thank you
[Music]